we are talking music and our brains with
Jack Black so Jack a lot of studies and
research have shown that the music that
we listen to when were teenagers kind of
stays with us and resonates with us do
you have any anecdotes or stories about
music in your teenage years well when I
think about my teenage years I think
about a lot of heavy metal oh I had like
a strange mix eclectic mix of music yes
because I I loved like Ozzy Osbourne
Black Sabbath yeah but then I also loved
like Bobby McFerrin and in high school I
did a lot of musical theater and I did I
was Pippin in production of Pippin you
played I was in Pippin yes is one of my
proudest moments
I had to drop a couple lbs I had to stop
eating that bean and cheese burrito just
on like tuna and some boring celery but
again then I got into Pippin shape
yeah and dude I was looking good so from
infancy it seems like our brains are
conditioned to respond to music and
sometimes we just can't help moving to
the beat why is dancing it's so
infectious long ago the ability to dance
was connected to the ability to survive
according to a 2006 study dancing was a
way for our early ancestors to bond and
communicate particularly during hard
times
as a result early humans who were
coordinated in rhythmic had better
survival rates
now our love and aptitude for dancing
contributes to a higher brain
functioning and a rise in serotonin
levels which in turn makes us more
physically and socially connected and
generally better at living a happy life
so danceOn
[Music]
you